you
ace devilishness former race car driver
Klaus needs fits describes the hybrid
drive porsche 918 spyder as the fastest
street-legal car anywhere they could do
everything a racing car can he tries it
out on the track in Valencia Spain where
he can push the spider to its absolute
limits
this superlative sports car equipped
with cutting-edge technology is limited
to just 918 units the hot-blooded design
easily takes the curve from the
racetrack to the city street the spider
hugs the asphalt low and wide
this a hybrid comes with three engines a
447 kilowatt rear mounted gasoline
engine and two electric motors one front
and one rear mounted it's a two-seater
with monocoque made of carbon fiber
reinforced plastic in the spirit of the
Carrera GT the Porsche 917 racer and the
RS Spyder the interior is a visual and
tactile delight with a boldly projecting
center console an instrument panel
boasting 3 gauge style displays and a
compact multifunctional steering wheel
the snug bucket seats complete the
racing cockpit feel
the large touchscreen works like a smart
phones replacing many of the traditional
switches a turn of this dial fires up
the regular engine
drivers have a variety of modes to
choose from the fully electric mode
shuts down the v8 engine completely but
what can the spider do on the racetrack
racing legend vault Aurora took the 918
spyder out for a spin
government he off da Vinci keys he's
never driven a street-legal car that was
so much like a competitive model very
impressive the car roars around the
racing track as if it'd been made for it
icns talk about
the 918 spyder is the first street legal
car to break the seven-minute mark for
the Nurburgring track
he's a electro motor at first he could
hardly believe it but the electric
motors give the car that extra punch you
feel their incredible power the moment
you tap the accelerator powers abide to
disguise podiatrist Bosma has never
experienced that with a conventional
engine and the way the combustion and
electric engines work together is
absolutely unique
our other guests tester Klaus needs fits
agrees that it's something very special
another foul lies the one he could tow
the car delivers an extreme performance
the moment he steps on the gas it pushes
him right back into the seat and the
brakes are every bit as responsive
gripping hard and fast he took it up to
200 kilometers an hour in just 7.7
seconds and it has a sound that goes
with the performance listen he says
the specs show just how extreme it can
be 0 to 100 km/h in just 2.6 seconds and
burning 3.1 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers but up to 10 times that when
driven close to its top speed of 345
kilometers an hour the two electric
motors put out 210 kilowatts of power
all together with the v8 they deliver a
nice 652 kilowatts been logged on rural
puts the pedal to the metal he feels
almost as if he were sitting in a space
shuttle he tried a racing start the day
before and he says he came very close to
blacking out your average driver could
hardly even imagine anything like this
he adds respectfully on the green say
the six efficient breakout become inaba
this is spoon fastball feel double
mention the concept is gonna cost it
catch the Porsche 918 spyder if you can
this is your speed freaks new dream car
those with my father close needs fits
admits that nobody actually needs a car
like this but he'd still like to have
one and he doesn't think he's alone in
that opinion celina
vw's cross up is the beefier brother of
the up at first glance it's striking
off-road look suggest good handling in
an SUV class the regular up has been out
since 2011 now it's gone cross-country
as the cross up but is it really
possible to turn a city car into an
off-roader when they think our test
Romano says from the inside he sees no
real difference to the regular up but
from the outside he does a little the
cross up features such typical off-road
details as front and rear chrome
finished aprons the chassis has been
raised by some 15 millimeters clearly
defined side skirts make for a dynamic
SUV look the honeycomb grille is
dominated by a plastic cladding and the
xenon headlights give the cross up an
adventurous air also new are the
standard roof rails
to what purpose were these changes made
then I cause up tofiq our a Volkswagen
explains that like the up the cross up
is designed for the mini car segment
which she expects to grow in the coming
years along with the market for off-road
vehicles and optically vw's cross up is
following the trend there's chronologies
in spent but aside from its conspicuous
design the cross up remains a city car
it's three cylinder gasoline-powered
engine is the only one available it
achieves 55 kilowatts of power and a top
speed of 167 km/h fuel consumption is
low at 4.7 litres per hundred kilometers
that's fine Manawa says the cross up
hardly differs from the regular app it
only smoothes out the bumps a little
better but without sacrificing any of
the driving pleasure it's nice and zippy
and it feels good the cross up can
handle some rough terrain it's greater
clearance lets it move easily off the
asphalt but it's not a whole lot more
adventurous than that no expeditions
into the Australian outback for instance
but it can hold its own unreasonably
level ground
in spite of its name the cross sub cuts
a stylistically harmonious and confident
figure the dashboard painted to match
the trim frames neatly arranged switches
the generous air vents reinforced the
designs modern and sporty tendency
our car Chester sums up
in Schism this time the whole the cross
up is well done of course all the
plastic outside in 15 millimetres extra
clearance do not make an off-roader but
it is definitely suitable for dirt roads
and forest tracks the new more rugged
design will cost about four thousand
euros more than a comparable regular up
and Germany the cross up starts at just
under 14 thousand euros but a GPS system
and AC will add about a thousand euros
to the price
Mercedes has now also introduced the
4matic system to its compact range the a
and B classes and the coupe a style CLA
sedan are now all available with
four-wheel drive the new development was
triggered by the production of the GLA a
compact SUV crossover it was unveiled at
the frankfurt auto show and goes on sale
in march the 4matic system was modified
specially for the mini off-roader it
allows variable amounts of power to be
delivered to the two axles and means
that compact car owners can now get the
added assurance provided by four wheel
drive
another Mercedes model rocking four
wheel drive is the Sprinter van the
system can be switched on at the touch
of a button electronic traction system
for ets does plenty of work for the
driver and there's also an optional hill
descent assist that can maintain a
predefined speed
as all hot the hem Sasha doubts the very
first wheel crafted by mankind looked
like this one we don't know today who
that inventor was but we do know that
Karl Benz revolutionized the world with
his version of the motorized passenger
car in 1886 back in 1914 years after
Karl Benzes patent global car sales
totaled 9500 for the stats for 2013
aren't out yet but the figure for last
year is expected to be around 87 million
preferences for class of car and brand
vary from country to country but what
about the actual process of buying a new
car
I'm their [ __ ] not our first example
sasha is outside cologne to talk to
Martin servidio he's interested in the
particular car buying a new car can be a
very emotional affair in Germany at
least customers here love perusing the
infinite array of special offers to put
together their dream abeel eighty or
ninety percent of customers who come to
the dealership are very well prepared
they've studied online and know what
they want internet so inform you of them
listen tral lhasa bowlin but Martin
looks out for is the right balance of
performance and safety it is important
when you have children ones that's four
million photos ultimate often dinkus
what are the priorities for people from
other parts of the world the price
economics efficiency for me it has to be
the price and how much it will cause you
to maintain the car afterwards price
price brand and dependability Oh for me
importance that not brand but the very
strong car for Tokyo economical not much
variation on that front end but there is
a big difference as regards another
factor I'd have to wait 16 weeks for a
pre-configured new car yes I waited over
six months the first time around three
months I'm though it's all the German
car buyers are prepared to wait but get
their car exactly as desired the same is
not true worldwide however as sasha is
going to show us both wagon sold more
cars in America than any other german
producer last year sasha is outside the
biggest VW dealership in New York to get
exclusive insights into the buying
habits of stateside customers comic-con
again Americans bought an estimated 11.2
million cars in 2013 with a population
of 317 million that translates into a
new car for one and 28 people
hello welcome to Volkswagen of Manhattan
yes sasha is wondering where all the
cars are tontis well we have 150 cars in
stock on the roof okay love to see a
roof covered in cars not something you
see every day no Sasha wants to know
what the procedure is when a customer
comes in here what's special here in
Manhattan is that the customer comes in
to the showroom and they test drive the
car today they also take a look at the
car inside and out and in most cases
they take the car home the same day or
if not today within one business day
dealers have to stock more vehicles on
site than in save Germany and as buying
such a quantity would be beyond the
financial means of most dealerships they
don't actually buy vehicles from the
manufacturer until they found a buyer
unlike in Germany where customers can
configure the car themselves buyers in
the u.s. of only a handful of variations
to choose from but dealers can swap cars
with a partner business if say the
desired body color is not in stock Jack
Viren is buying a new car would he wait
six months
so it would be difficult you would have
to be something real special
now be very I can't imagine what that
per year the view of most of his fellow
Americans oh it was there so I took it
immediately Matt got my call the same
day I usually just buy it the day of
your in dealership if you have the money
or the financing option you just walk
out the day out of if you if you have it
for three years fun engine it's the way
we do things in America it's always
simpler and things seemed to be getting
simpler for customers in Germany to now
why not follow our German dealer guesses
that eighty to eighty-five percent of
purchases he's processed in the last
couple of years are on credit those who
pay it all in cash like in the 1960s and
70s are a dying breed dr. pols car sales
in the US are also heavily influenced by
fluctuations in fuel prices weekends
when gasoline is cheap see more people
buying cars as the price of the pump
goes up sales decline the business of
car buying is in many ways an impulsive
issue in America
land rover is known for its top caliber
SUVs the first Range Rover was released
in 1970 and now the fourth generation is
on the market we take it for a spin on
and off the street
as for my English handling could be a
little tighter for montez's taste but
it's a relaxed drive anyway his father
he unveils father he's testing a Range
Rover with a volt equipment line it has
a 4.4 liter engine that creates 150
kilowatts of power and hits a hundred
kilometers per hour in under seven
seconds it has a top speed of 218 and
guzzles 8.7 liters of gas over 100
kilometers the powerful exterior Zen on
headlights and underbody protection make
it a real looker front cameras survey
the surrounding area the suspension can
be adjusted manually and the aluminum
body makes it about a hundred and 80
kilograms lighter than its predecessor
the rear lights are furnished with LED
technology it's on the light nothing
montes takes a look inside apart from
the high upright seating position the
interior doesn't feel like an SUV from
antis it's more like a luxury sedan
while flexes its position Nick metal and
as you know galindo vans it's a docked a
ellos vienen a look so slim Oh Xena
the interior is all about leather the
speedometer and rev counter our digital
the dashboard contains an 8-inch
touchscreen monitor with a controller
and the central console the front and
rear seats are of course leather covered
if you only have two rear passengers the
middle seat can be pulled down to create
an armrest
the trunk can be opened at the touch of
a button to reveal over nine hundred
liters of storage space if the rear
seats are stowed away again by pressing
a button that figure rises to 2030
litres of course the Range Rovers real
strength is how it deals with all kinds
of terrain here the new chassis and
terrain response system are the stars of
the show the system affects the chassis
engine and drivetrain and selects the
appropriate driving mode although
unruptured says Montes the Range Rover
cuts a good figure the only things that
limit where you can drive are the tires
you should always have all terrain
options for off-road driving with the
street tires we have on you should stick
to the lanes because if you get onto
really difficult ground you've got no
chance of getting out okay chief is
killing the fete pokémon kind of shots
in truth few drivers are likely to find
themselves in that situation but if the
road is blocked by water the size of the
vehicle and the 700 newton meters of
torque will get you through without a
problem
the CEO gave me you can't do this with a
luxury sedan the Range Rover can Ford up
to 70 centimeters of water which is more
than the previous edition don't try this
with a Jaguar Mercedes or an audi a8 the
water here is only 20 or 30 centimeters
deep that's nothing for this baby Fidesz
asalto Donny's the Range Rover lives up
to its billing as a car for both on and
off road situations the basic model
costs just over 89,000 euros in Germany
the model we tested will set you back a
lot more though coming in at a suite 107
grand
the new BMW s1000 are to not need a
steep learning curve to make it smart
a naked bike without fairies and with
160 horsepower for a very fair twelve
thousand eight hundred euros in Germany
it's raining here in Majorca not exactly
dream conditions for putting this
high-tech speedster through its paces
but the poor weather does have one
positive at least this new naked bike is
called the BMW s1000rr makes the dash to
a hundred faster than a 911 turbo in 3.1
seconds journalists law should say is
looking forward to handling this beast
although there are electronic assists on
board detainment conveniently the bike
also comes with a special rain mode time
for ignition
and take off
the rain mode rains in the throttle
response while the ABS and automatic
stability control engaged relatively
early so as to prevent wheel spin and
potential slip
it's Benny shenanigans our guest
reviewer likes the raw power an
appearance of the new S 1000 r he's wary
of maxing out the 160 horsepower
available on the slippery streets of my
orca today though you still have 136
horsepower in rain mode however more
than enough plus it's a totally safe
ride the brakes feel like casting
anchors but the racing abs is spot on so
on the one hand it's a thoroughbred but
one that's also good for a more laid
back front and Ralph a convincing
combination drop alki ignis and it
absolutely but saying the community on
raw racy and raring to go the design
speaks volumes you can see why BMW has
labeled its new street fighter a dynamic
roadster the imposing sound of the one
liter four-cylinder engine is channeled
through an almost delicate-looking
exhaust up front there are asymmetric
headlamps a nod to the bikes competitive
predecessor the s1000 Double R
the double are boasting 193 horsepower
has been dominating the super bikes
racing class in recent years the goons
at the BMW's motorbike design chief
reveals that when they made the fully
faired bike they had also thought at the
back of their minds they had to make a
naked bike so they designed the engine
to look really nice Sheldon Silva
started as our OC we became acclimatize
to the slippery my orca tarmac and
reveled in the sound of the are we kept
on turning up the gas safe in the
knowledge that the bike would control
its own speed typical for a naked bike
the wide handlebars allow you to sit
more comfortably than on the sports
version the same applies to your knees
comfort and power a thrilling
combination and the way it eases through
the rainy conditions make this bike a
very good bye remand anointing if Ralph
is forced to find a drawback it could be
the large number of identical parts the
rear looks almost the same as the double
our super bike then again for a
relatively cheap twelve thousand eight
hundred euros you get a dynamic roadster
with an awesome 160 horsepower so all
things considered he has no problem with
the shared platform concept custom
conceived for an autumn BMW will be
banking on its latest two-wheeled dream
machine to conquer all when it's
unleashed on the streets and the spring